I know I know I know I'm kind of sort of
slightly late just give me a second
working on it oh I was dumb and forgot
I'd taken down part of my setup and that
I then had to redo okay okay sorry about
that let's maybe have a little more
light going on how's that for a crazy
notion oh yeah okay thank you oh cool
cool cool
there we go hey everybody
oh yeah yeah ah of course a flying
muffin appeared so yes hope everybody
had a lovely weekend I had a very busy
one
I had a show debuting a new number
I've actually got I'm actually hosting a
show on Friday so this is uh is a packed
huh sort of chunk of time for me hi from
Australia oh cool what's with the muffin
ah the co-director I honestly don't
really know how to explain it it's
somehow become a thing I don't know why
it just kind of has how's the weather up
there today it rained a little bit but
not nearly as much as I thought it was
going to so not a bad day overall
weather-wise I was expecting it to sort
of get worse on me but it didn't
finally a wait to watch a stream Oh nerd
in a library dare I ask where you're
watching from some people are up like
crazy late to watch this so I'm trying
to figure out if you're up crazy late or
crazy early hmm
Hey hail Hydra
lovely it's only midnight here for once
oh well there you go Meghna
just watch her end game room for you
first time I've seen her in a video yeah
it was the first time I got her on so
far this year so depending on how long
you've been watching me you may or may
not have seen her before but yeah I had
really wanted to get her on more
frequently you aren't gonna see her
again later this month because we
already shot our 10 best characters of
Gotham video together so that'll be up
later this month I'm from Australia so
it's 8:30 in the morning oh that's not
that bad I mean great you do have to
pull it together enough to get going so
yeah okay fine fair enough
which of the Avengers players Avengers
characters would you cosplay as depends
are you asking me for movies or comics
because comics obviously opens a much
wider range of characters that I could
conceivably do a cosplay yeah so you got
to be more specific
full of pizza on the eve of my birthday
on the high from finishing a show to
some council livestreams perfect well
Alex happy birthday in advance
midnight in Ireland 7 o'clock 5 o'clock
MCU okay so if I was but I was got a
cosplay somebody from the MCU trying to
think if there was really any I mean I
would never have the capability of
putting this together but hella mainly
because I want that helmet the least
Steve could have done was kiss Bucky on
that you go Alchemist you you were left
wanting on that huh a random question
but if I paused it in another tab but do
you watch drag race III I do not I
watched the first four seasons of drag
race and partway into season 5 the the
show was beginning to bank more and more
more and more on the backstage drama and
the backbiting and the animosity between
Queens and I don't know how much of that
was the way the show was edited playing
up that element more or if they were
just getting intentionally you know kind
of snip your people hoping that they
clash but it was season 5 was starting
to remind me of the reasons why I don't
do drag shows anymore
and again as I've said I had a video go
up in the bureau wild channel last month
as I said they're like when I make my
complaints about drag in the drag
performance community take all of it
with a grain of salt because I've not
done a proper drag show in over a decade
so my experience while I stand by what I
say about it
is very out of date I hope so
there you go my spring allergies are
bothering me but this oh oh make me real
well I hope it helps I'll feel better I
don't know what happened you'll be a
real be a real boy now
hey there Claudia a reality shows seem
to be like that in general well yeah and
and I understand that as a factor but
the thing was it seemed like it was
getting worse at the show went along so
again how much of that was just how they
were choosing to present the footage
they had and how much of that was you
know the the contestants actually being
less pleasant with each other I don't
know but it was still it was evoking the
elements of drag that made me stop doing
it opinions encore playing for tonight
and Hulk dabbing the most important
parts I mean like I unless you know a
secret
I've never played for at night I mean
like I recognize for at night now those
got a cool little thing in Korg is like
kind of a weird enough good it's kind of
like slightly out of touch but like
thinks he isn't kind of guy that I'm
like yeah fortnight that sure that makes
sense
Hulk dabbing again he's it's just that
slightly cheesy thing that I could buy
banner what if he thinks he's cool I'm
doing so that I worked I you will you
think they will make a movie
Sam Dean Captain America well see the
thing is Claudia they've got the Disney
Plus show that officially the title is
falcon in the Winter Soldier I would not
be shocked if that is basically Sam
coming to terms with taking on the
mantle of Captain America and if they do
that they may not feel the need to
actually make a film about it they
certainly have an announced one for him
so I have a suspicion if that happens at
all it's a ways down the line it'll
probably depend on response and reaction
to the Disney Plus show what was your
favorite part of endgame oh god I'm not
even sure I hadn't like really thought
about breaking it down in terms of a
favor apart I just thought it was a
really strong film like overall
impressive
an impressive piece of work will I be
remembered as the muffin get yes Andrew
it's going to be on your tombstone you
need to accept that at this point do you
think the MCU risks franchise fatigue um
no no because they they've done a pretty
good job at having a different enough
vibe for each property that they kind of
existed into fairly independently so
like if you're tired of oh god I don't
know the sort of you know low-level
heist nature of the ant-man movies you
can go for a little bit of outerspace
buddy comedy with guardians of the
galaxy or you can I mean they'll be done
with Captain America but you can go for
you know heavier material with Captain
America movie so you know there's add is
it different enough feel from film to
film I think at least that it helps
shake it up now they're all still
superhero movies but they're different
enough and I think the superhero genre
is varied enough that there's no reason
for us to be getting fatigued
long as the movies are still decent I've
said before that if the tea if
anything's gonna bring on fatigue he's
gonna be mediocrity so that's what needs
to be watched out for us is not too many
films it's too many mediocre films which
I'm of the opinion Marvel as I've been
doing but you know to each their own
probably not gonna home that's another
conversation I'm praying the higher
showrunners writer for the Disney Plus
shows I've recognized the chemistry
between Mackey and Stan and use it well
well yeah I mean Disney and Marvel have
Dunham for the most part a pretty good
job of pairing creators to property and
honestly the biggest fall downs have
been on the TV side but somehow the
Disney Plus things are still being done
under Kevin Feige instead of under Ike
Perlmutter who normally heads up the TV
stuff so I'm not entirely sure how
they're getting away with doing that but
it that gives me more confidence because
it's the stuff done under him rarely
falters and when it does not by much why
do you always refer to Liz as your
partner not your girlfriend is she
gender fluid as well no this is not
gender food the reason I referred to her
as my partner is because girlfriend just
sounds it sounds very high school to me
it sounds very fleeting you know it does
I feel like the world the word
girlfriend doesn't properly convey the
level of commitment we have towards each
other so we use partner cuz she's she is
a partner in my life so it's I don't use
that to conceal her gender although I do
kind of get a kick out of using partner
and seeing people kind of like who don't
already know me or know her and like
trying to go oh Sosa manases Oh was he
talking about I'll admit to getting a
kick out of that but that's not the
reason that that I refer to her that way
this is more about Captain Marvel and I
hate to be the person to ask but did you
ever know the subtext between her and
her friends okay so I'm assuming you
mean the the potential for for a
romantic relationship between hold on
I'm going to adjust this a little
between Carole and Maria Rambo like the
thing was it didn't especially jump out
at me watching the film but I mean I'm
so averse to romantic entanglements and
most things anyway that I was never
gonna like pick up on on subtler hints
to that and personally I kind of
appreciate that she didn't have a love
interest and I'm not saying that because
like I wouldn't wanted to be with Maria
I would not have wanted that as a plot
element in general but I've certainly
seen a number of very compelling
arguments indicating relationship and
familial you know marriage even coding
between the two characters and I would
like to see that pay off I don't know if
it will we'll see um you know I buy it
sure I love Liz she is so cute yes she
is he's adorable I love her love her so
very much um have you managed to see the
far from home trailer ah yes on
sufferance so I'm actually gonna be
shooting a video after I wrap this up
I'm gonna be shooting a video on the far
from home trailer that'll go up on
Thursday so your folks are actually
gonna get a video a week this week so um
but in any case I wasn't going to watch
that trailer because I already knew I
was gonna watch the fight of mine far
from home and what I already know I'm
gonna watch something usually i watch
the initial teaser and then I usually
will try to not watch any additional
trailers after that because I already
know I'm gonna see it so anything you
show me is just gonna be a potential
spoiler unfortunately and I'm gonna warn
name anybody
right now who tried to do what I tried
to do in terms of avoiding the far from
home trailer I'm about to say what that
what was said in that thing so that's
your warning what the thing that got
brought up that everybody started
writing think pieces about which was the
hint at a multiverse that unfortunately
is the kind of thing that gets stuck in
frigging headlines and titles of videos
so I don't even have to watch them to
realize that that was a thing he hinted
at in that show then I'm like well mmm
fine I'll watch the damn trailer so I've
seen it I don't just like the trailer I
just like the fact that I feel like my
hand was forced in terms of watching it
so there's that so and like I like his
eyes I'm gonna shoot a whole video on
this but long story short it's really
weird to me that people are now doing
all the speculation on it Oh how's the
multiverse work cuz like you guys know
that the information source on there
being a multiverses Mysterio and
Mysterio's entire thing is deception
falsehood lies illusion like everything
about this guy is not what he presents
himself as so like why are we all so why
are so many people suddenly going oh
there's a ball deepers like what no I'm
not saying it's impossible that there is
but like I don't trust the source here
come on
you seem certain that the Black Widow
movie would be prequel but same was said
OOP sorry lost it hang on but the same
was said about the spider-man movie far
from home are you less certain about the
introduction who was saying that far
from home was a prequel who was saying
that I was the saying that I knew far
from home took place after endgame or
did I misunderstand your question uh yes
and despite my true trailer spoiled the
end game ending yeah which was Toni will
come back some time no he won't
no he will which is the main reason that
this is not going
to be a multiverse Tony is done Chris
Evans is done Pepper Potts should go
ahead Paltrow she's done the actors are
done their contracts are up they're
finished and they're not gonna introduce
a multiverse because if they do
immediately every single fanboy with a
with a frigging Theory channel or a blog
is immediately gonna start going oh
here's how they're gonna bring back Iron
Man they had to write an ending for hire
man Robert Downey jr. is not gonna play
this part forever
he's done he finished ah
how could he fool Nick and Nick talked
about the stuff for goodness sake okay
it it makes the way Mysterio works
Mysterio is an opportunist so if
something like the snap happens which is
this big you ever shaking event he can
probably very easily piggyback and go
ooh
they don't believe all sorts of crazy
stuff might have happened and I'll just
present with my fake whatever and tell
them this and they'll buy it and that is
my prediction wait is pepper done yeah
Gweneth Paltrow said she's she's
finished with these movies I prefer DC
Multiverse I'm not a big fan of
multiverses in general as a rule of
thumb and DC like you see when you say
you prefer the DC Multiverse
like which version because it's been
used very differently at very different
points and the way they have either
collapse it or brought it back has
oftentimes been not good so I don't know
what sort of rewards do you offer your
patreon sponsors looking for advice I'm
just setting mine up to support my
creative well-being working well I mean
you can go to the patreon page you can
see that you know the tears and the
rewards are right there but there's
things like the discord server or having
your name in the end credits of the
videos getting a signed business card
getting small merch items like buttons
and magnets
and keychains getting a signed copy of
one of my books commissioning a review
and you know in increasing cost odd at
each of these but like you can feel free
to go to the patreon and check it out if
you want like a point of guidance on
that I love when things that end
satisfyingly I hate the idea of
Wolverine ever coming back I mean like
some version of Wolverine will be
introduced into the MCU it's not gonna
be Hugh Jackman so that we got closure
on that Pepper Potts will turn out to be
a time lady who regenerated to build
pots even if they introduced multiverse
they can't convince our DJ to come back
he's set in Iron Man 2 you can't afford
me I mean I like the guys also the
oldest core cast member like I I think
he's just ready to be done
pre-crisis all the way multiverses get
confusing
um not always they can depending on how
you come at it like I Eve once you sort
of know the basic setup that they exist
I don't think they're that confusing if
you're not used to the concept yeah I
mean just the same way as time travel
can be confusing the first time you try
and wrap your head around a story that
uses it have you seen Disney's darkest
for 2021 2022 there are eight
live-action remake skip Meg don't dude
don't do this to me please please tell
me that's a joke I Oh God huh I guess
spider-man will doubt about him being
from another dimension but in the end
the twist it's true I really don't think
so I mean look I'm not saying it's
impossible
i Jim I rarely deal in declarative
statements but I just don't see it I
hope next Wolverine is really really
tiny as he's supposed to be it would be
kind of cool to see a five foot three
Wolverine which i believe is his cannon
height who's your ideal
for a recast MCU over een somebody I've
never heard of just like Hugh Jackman
was when he got the role in the first
place uh how's your week been so far
it's been okay um sorry should have
clarified multiverses get confusing for
me okay fair enough
I'm not kidding I saw it on Sabre sparks
Twitter earlier and was fuming ah
live-action remake of a stew bag full
video boy imagine seeing the the
practical prop of the living flesh
supercomputer that would be something so
Meg did did they actually have a list of
what they all were or just how many that
were happening because now that we've
dug this hole I'm curious as to how much
pain I should be in right now
have you gotten around to the twisted
DVD yet um I have it but but progress uh
I took the plastic off oh I'm I'm one
step closer to watching it uh I feel
really bad about that I'm but like I've
got that and I've got books people sent
me I'm still trying to get through stuff
maybe if I'm very lucky by my next
birthday I will have gotten through all
the stuff that was sent to me from this
past birthday we'll see um unless one of
those Disney remakes is hunchback I
don't want to hear I'm sorry I don't
want to hear that either
well I mmm I want to see Peter Dinklage
cast his puck
I love thorne guardians three but Adam
warlock is a must oh I totally forgot
that they hinted at Adam warlock
uh-huh um do you think the Snider cut of
Justice League should be shown I don't
care I mean like I I just don't care
should it be shown I don't like it won't
be like whether it exists let's take
four
let's take it as a given that the
Schneider cut does exist that there is
some rough cut version that was Snyder's
vision we're never gonna see it because
justice like there it will cost Warner
Brothers money to assemble polish and
release that they're not gonna do it
Justice League already lost them too
much money they're not gonna put the
money in to do it so even if it exists
we're never gonna see it should we be
able to I don't know again it's hard for
me to say cuz I don't care
I got a morbid curiosity I guess if it
was available I'd watch it just to do a
comparison but like I I just don't care
sorry I'm late but the toreador from
london checking in better late than
never yes agreed talking about anime
have you seen perfect blue yes I have
been a long time but yes I have that is
a good one
I might even own that try remember if
there was one I bought or not I cannot
remember uh Adam warlock Howard the Duck
in Cosmo I doubt we're gonna get much
out of Cosmo they oh did did people see
that Howard the Duck was in fact in
endgame like in like a one-shot blinking
you miss him like I didn't notice that
I've seen the stills though and and he
is in there so I know Chris Evans is
done but do you think he will still be
up for cameos I I don't know if he will
be I don't think they should I think
they I think they should just let it be
done because knowing the fan bases if
you even drop them in as in cameo people
will start asking when do we get them
again when do we get them again and like
at that point it's almost just teasing
the audience and I don't I don't think
there's much to be gained from that
favorite Satoshi Kon film I'm not
entirely sure who that is that's not to
say I haven't seen any of their films
but it is to say I don't recognize the
name I'm from the UK what's your taste
in anime
um selectively I'm more partial to anime
films than TV shows because anime TV
shows tend to dip into more of the anime
tropes that I don't like whereas I feel
the films tend to do that the the sort
of stuff that turns me off a bit less
Satoshi Kohn is the one who did perfect
blue what else have they done besides
perfect blue because I'm not sure if
I've seen anything else from them or not
again Gustav lurking cat needs a movie
um I don't know if he needs a movie but
rocket needs to see him and lose his
crap like he like he did in the comics
um Hilda was one of only four Emmy
Awards that she was nominated for screw
you Daytime Emmys I don't pay attention
like I I forget that the Emmys happen I
never keep track of what like that
considering of that I it's a war show
relating to a medium that I do enjoy
which is television like I totally
forget about the Emmys uh Cosmo was in
the credits of volume two needs to be in
volume two
oh yeah I guess he was wasn't he I've
forgotten that it's been a while since
I've ivory watched some of these Satoshi
Kon has also done millennium actress
which I've seen and liked very much
Tokyo Godfather's I have not seen and
paprika paprika was okay was weird was a
little creepy in ways that I didn't
enjoy at times it was interesting wasn't
that one didn't quite work for me uh yes
I think we can add do you like anime or
what and I do like to the to the drink
to the drink questions list a
live-action remakes perish from you and
me both holy cow
thoughts on the new sonic trailer I
think I mentioned this last livestream
it's just the 90s
thing that ever 90s it's it's insane
so I can stepped out of a time like I
wonder may is that is that the
multiverse that happened with the snap
as we opened up a portal to an alternate
universe where it's still the 90s and
this movie dropped out of that because
that's what it feels like hey did anyone
saw Howard the Duck when last five the
Avengers endgame happened i I didn't
spot him but I've seen these the the
pictures what animates he'll like Cheers
I don't I don't have a drink with me up
here ah sorry about that um the problem
with a Doctor Who movie is who has
blamed the doctor no the problem the
Doctor Who movie is you only get to do
one story whereas Mott what I love about
Doctor Who is the fact that literally
every story you know every episode of
every two episodes gets to be something
completely different and I don't I
wouldn't feel like we got anything more
by stretching one story out into an hour
and a half to two hours I just I just
don't see the benefit in that paprika
was one of the inspirations for
inception I did know that I sort of saw
the bleed over a little bit there still
it's still just didn't quite work for me
do you know the youtubes were implicitly
pretentious nope have not heard of that
one I frankly feel bad for age of Ultron
I have no idea what people have against
I personally prefer to the first one I
like the thing about age of Ultron is it
has some of my favorite scenes in Marvel
to be honest there it has wonderful
components they just don't quite fit
together right so it's like all these
individual pieces of an engine are
meticulously crafted and perfectly
polished and they are the best that they
can be but like they don't quite fit
together and then the overall engine
kind of sputters as it goes along that's
sort of my take on age of Ultron I think
does get like a loop it gets treated a
little rougher than it deserves but I do
think it doesn't quite pull together the
sonic god the sonic news made me nervous
most animators aren't unionized so
they'll likely be overworked oh yeah
yeah the fact that they're talking about
going back and fixing the look of Sonic
a yeah that there's gonna be some people
made or some very ungodly hours for that
and that's wrong so there you go
I'm so happy you ranked Castro Volvo so
high in your ranking it was one of my
favorite episodes of all whoo but
Davison was my doctor growing up which
is fair and like I'm capable of
recognizing wanted story with Davison
works really well despite the fact that
I don't really enjoy him so I like it
whoa whoops sorry
I can I can detach those those things
sorry I might kick the tripod
did you see the stew bag full video
about Buffy Nathaniel featured in it as
a stick figure recently you go back to
his stuff because I support him on
patreon and there's a certain tear on
Stupak Phil's patreon where he will draw
you as a stick figure and put you in
videos sporadically so you haven't kept
track of which ones I'm in but like
going back about a year a little more
than that I think you can find me
sprinkled throughout his videos in
stick-figure form and I love those makes
me very happy just own it let the teeth
Hedgehog be [ __ ] a hedgehog be horrible
look the Sonic the Hedgehog movie is
going to be terrible
no matter how the Hedgehog looks the
Hedgehog looking as bad as he does
doesn't help and kind of makes it worse
but fixing that is not going to suddenly
make it a good movie I mean that's the
sad reality thoughts on chip know
scrapping the Daleks and Cybermen have
not
anything about that so I have no
thoughts does Ironman die in the end
bombing we're talking spoilers so yeah
yeah it does I mean like normally I say
if you don't talk spoilers in here but
like it's it's in the name of the
livestream I said they would be here
sonic has perfect he'd like yours yeah
thousands of dollars worth of words
orthodontia and many years of crap in my
face to get these teeth the trans gamer
girl is aware of they just outed how old
they are no shame in that if you could
choose the Doctor Who story to adapt
into a movie peter cushing movie style
which would it be if any again I'm not
sure I'd I go for the you know the whole
idea of doing a movie and part of it is
like I can't think of a story that I'm
like oh if only they did this with a
movie budget I'm like yeah so I don't
know I just like I can't get my brain to
get into a gear where I can't even
really answer that but the Sonics does
sonic have five nipples like real
hedgehogs well I mean maybe they'll add
that in when they fix it not as old as I
am
should have been Clint not Natasha I
mean I I think the story would have
worked either way I think in a lot of
ways the the expectation would have been
Clint cuz I know like people have been
expecting him to die ever since it was
revealed that he had a family because
like you give a character more to lose
and it's like Lou it'll be so tragic
when we kill him so I'm kind of like
that it wasn't Clint for that reason if
nothing else but that's me still morning
in New Zealand oh yeah you're lucky Kim
Gotham season 5 was the biggest
disappointment since my son
oh that Oh Gotham season 5 wasn't pretty
big disappointment though yeah are we
doing endgame spoilers then I mean like
we've kind of talked the movie already
but I mean they're on the table so by
all means how does how does the patreon
tier work for the whole the whole what I
don't even know what to make of that
sorry first real life sonic and then
illumination making a Mario movie I mean
like I'll wave our trailer on that one
I mean illumination has made decent
movie and I actually think Singh is
legitimately good so you know and that's
not to say that I expect Amara movie
made by illumination is gonna be awesome
but you know I'll see a trailer we'll
see how it goes
lilo and Stitch live-action yeah I know
about that one hop take Captain America
under soldier is only good because of
the Winter Soldier scenes the conspiracy
stuff was boring as modern the filming
was determine on interesting interesting
take wrong but interesting top three
Marvel characters that are still alive
after endgame Peter Parker so top top
spots easy Peter Parker rocket nebula
been watching your channel for over two
years and based on your interest I would
recommend you watch a show called dr.
burr oh I'll have to check that one out
them I think I just don't like
elimination because of their philosophy
make things cheap and appealing to the
masses to make Bank
I mean how fair it works have you seen
or read the trifid give me day of the
trophy I have
I know what it is but no I haven't have
you seen it talked about the new
spider-man trailer yes I did I'm
actually I'm gonna be shooting a video
on it that'll go up on Thursday so I
don't know why they're doing live-action
Lee Louis look I don't know why they'd
well no I know why they're doing all of
it but yeah let's bring back Max
Headroom only if Matt Frewer does it
again no one else has any business
playing Max Headroom I will say that
definitively anything LGBTQ in endgame
yes I mean not from a major character
but early on in sort of the an extended
scene that set five years after the snap
there's kind of a meeting that Steve
that Captain America is in of people you
know just trying to cope and move
forward with their lives and there's a
guy in there and I guess somebody said
it was one of the directors playing this
part you know talks about you know I
went on a date and it was weird and you
know he mentions eventually a telling
the story he drops the pronoun he so his
date was with a guy so it's not a named
character but yes there is a gay people
at least exist it's more than JK
Rowling's given us so did you know the
gay character at the beginning of
endgame was one of the Russos I I knew
that because of comments on the on the
review
Captain America kissed his niece though
like niece Biden by marriage not nice by
blood not that that makes that whole
Sharon Carr thing any less weird it's
still weird but don't make it weirder
than it is okay
do you like the British comedy series
Red Dwarf I've got a video up called why
red dwarf is awesome so no no I don't
really like it all that much yes
smeghead
JK Rowling put that character in there
so that she could later say how
for is he really non-binary and into
Bond itch I mean here's the thing I
could actually see Thor being into
bondage but not realizing it because
he's only ever been hit hard enough for
it to register in the middle of a fight
so I don't think I think if he ever got
smacked around in a non combat setting
he might realize he kind of likes it ah
snake head who's Max Headroom I saw I
came in the back to the future
Oh Oh God how do you explain Max
Headroom max hey max headroom is a
product of the 80s I really don't know
how else to explain this they also they
also have sorted the stone with a writer
producer from Game of Thrones I have to
hope you're joking ever seen Fawlty
Towers yeah I've seen the first series
of Fawlty Towers in some of the second
series guardians of the galaxy plus
Avengers guardians of the Avengers if
Sony let Disney do it do you think an
MCU spider-verse crossover would work I
mean the thing is the I I couldn't I
couldn't find the most reliable source
but I believed it that they had wanted
to try and get at the very least Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield into voice
some variants of spider-man but in
addition to I think not being able to
get the schedules to work or possibly
they weren't interested they also
decided to to narrow down like because
that's some of the conceptual stage is
never gonna be way more spider people in
that film than there are so like I could
totally see in a future spider-verse
movie cameo in the Tom Holland
spider-man in there somewhere I could
absolutely see them doing that
I don't want it the other way around
because I think as much as i bitched
about the whole multiverse thing like I
feel like there's enough separation in
most people's mind between live-action
and animation that people wouldn't take
the animated film implying that it's
connected to the live-action as canon
the way that they would the live-action
and playing is connected to the animated
one as canon so I actually wouldn't have
the same huge issues with that that I
would with the possibility of there
being multiverse in the MCU which maybe
is splitting hairs but I don't know
that's that's just how it lands for me
oh my god you know put the image of Thor
bend over spanking horse while black
widow canes in thanks you are welcome
I now need someone to draw that for me
next time you go to a comic-con
commissioned that from an artist please
did someone explain nebula killing her
past self I mean what is there to
explain the the way that the time travel
works she's it's not back to the future
so her future self isn't gonna phased
out from killing her past self nothing
will ever top the BDSM on the he-man
movie where he man gets whipped but okay
yes okay the the eighties the he the
eighties he-man has as he mam
completely bare chested being whipped by
a character they'd created for the
movies called blade well while Skeletor
watches and it really looks like he's
getting off to it he like this little
like he's like clutching is his uh
stabbing like Oh every time the whip
cracks it's it's so kink is insane oh I
love that movie it's not good but I
loved it so much and I'm pretty sure
that this convert this part of the live
stream is now gonna get this demonetized
I'm calling that now I really need to
defend back to the future I
the whole series on my channel but back
to the future and endgame has slapped me
in the soul look anything doesn't say
that Back to the Future is bad it just
said that's not how time travel is gonna
work here McGee you don't have to take
it as a hit on your beloved franchise um
a lot of 70s and 80s movies must have
inspired a lot of kinks let's be fair I
mean like in Bolton both ways a lot of
there were a lot of filmmakers into like
very plainly putting their I mean still
like keep an eye out for the way Joss
Whedon or Quentin Tarantino shoot
women's feet one of these days keep an
eye out for that
so like filmmakers with fetishes 8nu
back to the future is BS quote Scott
Lang in in an end game yes because he
was trying to use that as a factual
reference which it isn't you're taking
in a little port like I get that you
love back to the future but you're
taking it a little personally Tarantino
doesn't even try to hide his foot fetish
especially in death Proof ya know it's I
mean it's it's I'm not gonna say it's
something that that maybe you would
think to look for but it's one of those
things once it's been pointed out like
you noticed so much ever see the
Deadpool music video based on Gaston no
no I have not
my little ace heart is so awkward in
this conversation Oh Kara
oh no not trying to not trying to be
exclusionary make des monetize a drink
prompt uh maybe you don't see the hate
comments that he get about Back to the
Future the internet internet is harsh
okay look that's true you'll probably
get similar if not worse comments though
well yes but I also get rid of them so
any news about the new Dark Crystal
movie well it's not a movie it's a
series I mean no
they there has not been anything new on
that that I know of time travel it's a
cornucopia of disturbing concepts I
always liked the Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy take on time travel which is
that you can go back and change stuff
but ultimately stuff's all gonna work
out more or less the same anyway because
it's it's just all it all just be fine
and adjust so like for example it says
that there's no you don't cause a some
sort of universe destroying paradox by
going back in time and becoming your own
grandmother or grandfather there's
absolutely nothing wrong with being your
own grandmother or grandfather that a
well-adjusted family can't learn to cope
with so that's kind of always been my
preferred take on time travel if I'm
being completely honest now that you see
an endgame are you gonna rank the Marvel
movies not until I see far from home
then I will rank them because then I'll
get to be done for the year I shall
aside from bomb voyage who is the
greatest Pixar villain that's see I
don't think of the villains first and
foremost in Pixar um hmm I mean it
probably would be sin Jerome to be
honest I just found the he-man movie on
Stan so guess what I'm doing tonight
have fun Frank Langella is amazing as
Skeletor in that yeah amazing
have you ever seen what we do in the
shadows no neither the film nor the
series III have not seen either one like
I saw the trailers and like I just I
just worry that it's either a bit too
much of the cringe style humor which it
just is not my bag and that's not for me
to say that it's bad but it's like I
don't enjoy that I just don't
just the movie I actually didn't know
there was a serial it isn't the series
out yet or has that happened yet I
actually lost track I know the film
should be on Amazon Prime the prop the
prospector I mean Kelsey Grammer come on
well I mean look Kelsey Grammer can
voice a good villain but like you tell
me Kelsey Grammer villain I'm gonna
think Sideshow Bob and he always wins so
do you think the x-men franchise could
ever be great I don't know how to answer
that because the franchise as we know it
is ending and when x-men Reid comes back
in whatever form Disney we're always
gonna be it's gonna be completely
different beast could that be good sure
but I'd literally know nothing about how
that's going to be so to say that it
could be good well yes it could but I
have no reason to believe that it will
or won't be I have no information to go
off more coffeeCup sightings in every
movie Oh
I barely way more people noticed that
Starbucks cup in Game of Thrones than I
did and people oh boy I got blowback on
that last game of Thrones review too bad
wasn't expecting that but it happens I
love the fur I watched the first episode
of the new duck tails gotta love David
Tennant as a Scottish duck yeah okay
people if you have not seen the premiere
episode of the new duck tales I'm pretty
sure it's still up for free on youtube
find it watch it it's awesome I think
there's a bisexual couple on the TV show
any updates on a drunk review of Dark
Phoenix like I don't know I'll figure
out how I'm gonna tackle that thing I
want to get closer to actually having to
watch it are you disappointed hot pie
hasn't played a big role in the last
year it's of g.o.d no I mean like Popeye
got is you know we saw he was okay
that's all that's all we needed you know
that's all we needed until he ends up on
the Iron Throne at the end cuz that's
obviously what's gonna happen
duh ah I wonder if anyone caught that
cup and went maybe no one will notice I
would say more likely nobody noticed it
because they could have afforded to CGI
it out I bet you'd that nobody caught a
patreon tear drunk reviews oh I suppose
like if I wanted to I could make it what
hey we'll be higher than just the
Commission review tear and it would have
in it could only be for like two
episodes of a show or a movie I could
and I say it would be a higher level
tear cuz it's asking more of me than
just watching the thing so I mean maybe
maybe as a test run see if anyone's even
interested in and giving that a shot
we'll see the famous kidney pie will
bring a thousand years of peace I'm
afraid of nothing those reviews will be
drunk after dark Venus yes it's the only
way I will be able to cope I feel that
use the game take a shot every every
time certain question is asked that's an
excuse to drink well see you say that
except that like I said I forgot to grab
a drink for this one so and also I don't
keep track of the channel well enough to
on that the ducktales reboot is made
even more awesome when you learn
Catherine Tate voices magic of de-spell
yeah I keep forgetting that and yes and
that is awesome we could crowd fun some
drunk reviews oh dear I think I feel
like I'm making a rod for my own back
with this oh boy
do you think Galactus will be the next
overarching MCU villain um yes but I
think he could be
but I do not think there will be an
overarching like grande everyone has to
come together to defeat the villain for
a while I think they are gonna let
endgame put a close on the big crossover
universe world ending threats for a bit
and I think they're gonna have it be
smaller more focus more character
focused stuff for a while or at least
that's what I hope that's the smart
thing to do because it's scale-wise you
can't top endgame
I'm not gonna say you can't top it
quality wise but scale and scope I don't
think you can so I think they're just
not even gonna try for a while we need
to we need to crouch under liver
transplant to then oh boy
you ever check out tangled series and
Rapunzel's tangled adventures no I never
did I never got around to those from
tumblr Game of Thrones Walking Dead and
Breaking Bad in Super who luck for manly
man oh dear yes I hope it gets smaller
for a while to like I just I think it
has to
I like there's no other way to move
forward for a bit I was gonna say
something like you know somebody
mentioned crowdfund me like I'm I'm
debating whether next year whether I'm
gonna put out the the invite to like get
stuff off the the Amazon wishlist again
or if I'm actually gonna like do a
GoFundMe or so or something like that
for something specific I'm debating that
I'll I mean I've got what 10 months to
figure that out I may do that out game
of walking bad are you gonna watch Good
Omens oh yeah oh you better believe I am
how about Joker I mean I'll I plan to
see it I really don't know what to make
of it I'm not turned off I'm intrigued
but I'm also like very cautious about
this there's even a wine bottle behind
this guy's party animal actually this
wasn't wine this was double bourbon
cider is what this was Oh
preserve the scent I mean I I like these
kinds of bottles so I tend to hang on to
them with the crowdfunding beef for one
big video or a project hey I've got a
few ideas for if I ran a crowdfunding
like on my birthday what it would be and
I don't I mean I I don't I don't want to
I don't want to say yet cuz I'm figuring
that out
um favorite cocktails white Russian is
the drink of choice for channel pub
White Russians are very good um like I'm
I don't have like a go to cocktail I'm
very mood dependent like I can I could
just as easily go for a vodka cranberry
as a margarita has a whiskey sour you
know I I'm I'm the kind of person who
will browse the cocktail menu and
waiting for something to jump out at me
have you seen Excalibur from 1981 I have
not I know you wanted to get more into a
Big Finish started a wishlist feature
yes I did see that I haven't like looked
into exactly how it works yet but vodka
and orange juice is always a winner
Oh screwdrivers that that's that just
reminds me of college drinking too much
for my part
my ideal cocktail is a chai latte what
are you putting in your chai latte Long
Island iced tea and Jager not together
I do like Jager actually like seems to
turn a lot of people off I do I do enjoy
it um what's your take on the GAR grow
as a animated series very first episode
of animation junkie ever did was on
gargoyles because it's awesome ah
nothing because they don't drink respect
absolutely nothing wrong with that can
you say hi to Jay hi Jay uh you should
see Excalibur it's got Helen Mirren is
Morgan la Fey mm-hmm like I've heard
decent things about it but at this point
I think I might have waited too long
like I I suspect is probably just very
dated in many ways that might be tough
for me to roll with or at least take
seriously have you ever been to Wales no
I have not
I've been to England I've been to London
that's it I haven't done the UK outside
of that worst was a Harvey Wallbanger I
actually don't know what's in those
dirty gin martini
ah that my daughter's mother dirty dirty
martinis dirty vodka MOT martinis that's
her actually dirty vodka martini extra
dirty that is her drink of choice
have you seen crawl no I have not that
one I know is too dated for me I used to
wonder if my teetotal in asexuality was
causing me to be a social recluse but
nope I just have no real social graces
well at least now you know that and now
you're not left wondering I understand
oneself it is a lovely thing
I know you haven't seen legends in
tomorrow's season four yet but I can
already tell you're gonna love Charlie
I'm intrigued
as you are a huge fan of the final
episode of Dexter how do you feel when
people talk trash about it then Ben I
can't even joke with you about that like
I wish I could roll with you we could
have a fun back and forth here but it's
just so bad I can't even joke and gamer
drinking games
both Wow glass is off yeah I got serious
there for a minute uh somehow had a
Malibu sunrise and had a Long Island
iced tea one night last week and didn't
get tipsy at all good or bad you can all
decide impressive I'll go with that
some drinking games are end games what's
your favorite 80s cartoon the Real
Ghostbusters hands-down
no question I think not necessarily the
show as a whole but I think it's that is
a show where the good episodes are still
good I can still hold up
not every episode of the show does but
the episodes that I own that entire
series and I'd love to going through it
because the episodes that I remember
being good are still so good any book
tips on reading or writing I have been
doing a lot more writing lately which
I'm trying to hold the momentum on that
because because it feels good to be
doing
you should drink type it's a Brazilian
drink I don't even know how to pronounce
that anyone old like me remember Astro
Boy
I know Astro Boy never washed it you
know what I have seen episodes of though
Gigantor hahahaha so not that far off
age-wise how about favorite 90s cartoon
ooh probably gargoyles have you seen in
game what's your favorite music what are
your pronouns cheers everybody finish
your drinks
nicely done Meg tape hear Enya k / Enya
no I have never tried that Batman the
Animated Series solid choice scariest
movie you've ever seen 1978 version of
invasion of the body snatchers still hey
that movie still freaks me out I've been
seeing since I was 13 it still freaks me
out is there anyone here who isn't
writing something well good that that is
the nature of being an aspiring writer
we're all always working on something
it's never finished it's never published
but we're always working loving the hair
I'm actually okay I'm gonna go and get
this recolored on Thursday probably
won't show up on a video until Monday's
game of Thrones review but this is I'm
gonna get this recolored and freshened
up and actually I'm gonna do something
that I very rarely do and that is I'm
gonna make a page patreon exclusive
video just sort of a fun you know me and
and the the hairdresser that I work with
and just making a fun little thing out
of out of getting all this done and now
I like I said I almost never do patreon
exclusive because I don't want to feel
like I'm gating off content but that's
the kind of silly thing that I don't
feel like
I never put on the channel in general so
that that'll end up being a patreon
exclusive video which is it will only be
the second one I've ever done so if you
are interested in seeing that and aren't
already supporting me on patreon feel
free to do that I need to figure out
like a better way well I mean I don't
know if I need to figure out a better
way to plug patreon if or I just need to
keep at it
cuz it like I'm at a I'm at a weird
transition every point where I feel like
if I could if I could make an outright
plea seems like too much of a beggin
word for the patient of support like in
a video that I know is gonna be well
viewed I feel like it would it would
boost the the thing the problem is
people at my work know about this
channel I don't know if anybody watches
it but it makes it you know potential
bit of at best awkwardness but the the
truth is at this point where I I'm at a
I'm not a level where if I could get 10%
of my subscriber base which is about the
number of people who can who
consistently watch nearly every video to
commit to to $1 a month on the patreon
it will be tight that would cover my
bills so it's maybe we'll get there I
don't know but it's it's one of those
things where it's fun to think about
until I start to think about how likely
is it actually gonna be and then I get
bummed out and I don't know I don't know
I don't know please add purple and blue
that I mean well you'll see what gets
added when when it shows up and actually
haha it's funny I say I say you'll see
it in the Monday Game of Thrones video
but normally
the Hat on for the game of Thrones so
maybe you'll have to tune into next
week's live stream see the hair Oh we'll
see make that a a nice incentive for
everybody how to trigger or Marvel hands
just say Batman sucks Oh Dan you're a
genius but you hurt my soul can you
recommend books for someone who wants to
learn how to write like if you're
looking for a guide book like how-to
books on how to write I've never had
much luck getting through them just cuz
they bore me so oh I don't have anything
like that that I can really recommend I
mean just read what inspires you and
then write but it inspires you to write
that's all I can offer a dollar a month
you say need to check out the exchange
rate and my bank you know
I appreciate it I wish I could give more
month what college is eating up my money
like look here's the thing as much as I
know I can get a little a little overly
pleading when it comes to the patreon I
don't want anyone to think that they are
somehow letting me down by not
supporting it like if you just watch
that makes me happy if you share a video
that you thought was particularly good
with someone who wouldn't otherwise see
it that's amazing
if if you watch these live streams and
talk with me that's terrific
if you support me on patreon that's
great if you don't do any of that stuff
and you just watch an occasional video
that's great too like this thing this
entire thing is way bigger than I ever
thought it was gonna be already so I I
really really hope that I never come
across as ungrateful for what I already
have with the fact that I tend to pine
for a little more so I gotta be careful
about that recently got my BBA and
marketing if you'd like I can check out
the best practices to promote patreon
for you give you some tips
honestly I I wouldn't I wouldn't say no
I I would be
happy to take a look at them I would
love to Commission on patreon one of my
favorite series to get your take for my
birthday
is there a waitlist how does that work
okay well if you're commissioning a
series okay the the commission tier
there is currently four commission tiers
there's the base one which is currently
all filled up because it's limited slots
on each of them there's the base one
which is just either a single film or
two episodes of a TV series that's 60
there is there's the book tier which is
a hundred there's I think it's three
hundred for a full season of a show
depending on how long episodes are and
how many episodes there are but but yeah
so if you're commissioning me for a and
bi series like a season a full season or
if it's British series there is a Tier
four that depending on how long it is it
might be negotiable at a lower tier you
like send me a message send me a direct
message through patreon through Twitter
through email whatever and we'll talk
about what it is you're thinking about
and I'll work with you just to figure
out how feasible and workable it is
thank you well thank you very much
you've never come across as ungrateful
that is good to hear uh it was my
channels one-year anniversary today yes
channel pup I saw that super pleased
with the response I had two things I did
mention you in there amongst other
youtubers that are important to me
hashtag not a plug oh dang man ah trying
a thing
what's your pronouns drink everybody
drink
assuming you're of age if you're under
21 don't drink ever seen the centurions
no don't know that one which do you
think is the most scary movie monster
ever I don't
scariest I don't know I mean the best
movie monster I'll hang on why the heck
did it do that hang on a second oh I see
what happened I gotta wrap this up soon
anyway ah there we go that's better um
the best movie monster is the xenomorph
I mean that's that's just a fact yeah
there she is um I don't know if she's
necessarily the scariest I say she cuz
that's a queen I'll send you a message
on patreon cool we'll talk it said well
oh it's sad what's your partner's
pronouns my partner my partner's is is
just she her pronouns Liz is not gender
fluid like I am 18 is the legal age to
drink in my country okay but are you 18
that is the important question here my 3
year old says hi hi kid 3
I remember my kid being 3 do you have a
PA box I do the address is in the
description of every video so check any
video it's it's there I actually haven't
checked the Peele box and a little over
a week I should do that you and claw
include the price of the show or movie
in the review um
again that's something that sort of
worked out on a case-by-case basis
generally speaking yes because most
things are either available streaming
and in the few cases where I've had to
buy something it's been like 5 6 bucks
so like the cost of the Commission
review I just I just accept that as an
expense um I had one issue where the
specific thing that was commissioned I
couldn't like find at a reasonable price
and we renegotiated to something else so
if price ends uh if if price our
difficulty of me acquiring something
that you want me to review ends up being
a factor we may have to work out
something else
but generally speaking assuming
it is not hard to get then that's just
built into the Commission price already
you can drink age 18 here in Australia
yeah I'm 29 for the next 10 years haha
um yeah my uh my daughter's mother will
be turning 25 this year again for well
no I won't say how many times cuz that
that would be speaking and it's not my
place to say what her age is have you
seen stranger things yes brilliant first
season did not like the second one very
much at all
I'm 23 but all I got is Pepsi oh dear
Lord
who did you who did you hurt that you're
that you are forced to to suffer it's in
such a way oh that reminds me Pepsi or
coke neither I don't like soda
it cost me $16 see the Dalek movie in
theatres three times I don't I don't
like the taste of alcohol valid umm I
don't like the taste of some alcohols so
I'll have Pepsi over pineapple pizza oh
you shut our mouth there is nothing
wrong with pineapple on pizza in fact it
is glorious I will not hear anyone speak
otherwise I've spoken I don't know why
I'm is like turning in the Batman voice
any book any book tips any book tips
look it's just the tip be gentle it'll
be fine
do you play tabletop games the indie
Pathfinder color like occasionally not
regularly project oh god the prawn chips
yeah God that would yeah those we're so
gross
are you still enjoying the new pink
album yes I am I am i I mean I like walk
me home best but it's it's it's a good
album overall I am enjoying it you're
gender-fluid be flowed unusually
followed to mail that well i boys i
voiced I forced my voice down
there for a second because I went all
well all dark and gritty I'm not sure
that you could handle this kind of
intensity or you know you just left me
out of the room whatever works poison
ivy or Harley Quinn um poison I because
I feel like she is more consistently
done well Harley Quinn is great when
done well but she is very problematic
when done poorly
Batman burlesque I mean well the other
thing I'm all and actually I was gonna
say I'm biased is have done a poison ivy
number except I've also done a Harley
Quinn number so I can't be biased I've
done both um and yeah there are plenty
of uh a Batman but mostly Batman villain
burlesque numbers out there you could
totally base an entire show around it no
I can't handle it please stop now that's
a good voice if you can maintain it like
like I'm I was like scratching up my
throat going that low like hang on a
second trying to figure out how low I
can get it where it's like still within
my natural register where it's not like
me forcing it into a more cartoony voice
which I guess would be around here but I
mean you'll also notice I sound like a
little bit more disaffected speaking
this low because I tend my voice tends
to go up when I get excited about stuff
so
I think that's one of the reasons that
my voice usually if you hear me
consistently talking in this low
register I'm probably either very time
and tired or very frustrated or bummed
out about something because when I have
fun it just it goes it goes higher that
is just that is just kind of what
happens are you feeling lucky pub Punk
best man is the Batman is the best man
yeah I'm not even drinking what is wrong
with me Batman is the best rogues
gallery only one that comes close to
Spiderman's blood yeah pretty much flesh
does have a very fun one though I'd be
fun to watch a DC review with that voice
who's gonna die Danny or Jon Snow both
go back to regular voice I'm sorry I
feel like I just traumatized people uh
[Music]
have you seen the Dirk Gently series on
Netflix I have not I never did get
around to that one I'm very wild live
stream you started talking about
something nerdy and I noticed you went
into Nathaniel voice yeah yeah I
probably did cuz what like um when I do
the beer the very videos are the one
time I did the live stream naturally it
got like I'm doing these streams of my
voice range now so that'll pick up into
my upper register and again I I don't
want to put it too high because you know
you flip it up into falsetto and like
that's just that's just a mockery of a
feminine voice and you don't want to go
there but in a more thoroughly feminine
mindset if my voice actually would kind
of naturally pitch up to around here but
you get me talking geeky and it tends to
if not necessarily bring out the guy in
me at the very least kind of put the the
guy side of myself back into the mix and
it brings it down to around here which I
feel like is my standard voice range ah
my friend keep nagging me to watch like
a movie to because I love the first one
but I grew out of it and really don't
care should I watch it not only should
you watch like a movie too but I just
got my copy in my blu-ray copy and
probably in June I am going to make a
video devoted to breaking down why this
movie is not only better than the first
one but just flat-out amazing
so like I'm going full like a video
essay on this mofo that's how much I
liked like a movie - did you find the
Big Lebowski reference funny since
Bridges was in the MCU
that wasn't the reason I found it funny
the reason I found the The Big Lebowski
reference funny was because literally
seconds before Tony said it
Liz leaned over to me and said and then
he and then Tony calls him Lebowski so
that was why I found it funny I hope you
do more Vera screams I'd be up for that
it's just that like I'm so rarely in the
full makeup when I'm at home more of an
than not if I'm doing the full makeup
it's because I have a show or I have a
photo shoot or something so I'm very
rarely at home to do a stream while I'm
doing all that I hear you half pêche of
a lot of the time yeah it's a tennis
fair have you seen us yet no I've gotta
wait for either streaming or DVD or
something at this point what's the best
movie you watched one of the best at
least well I actually don't know how to
answer that one cuz I do distinguish do
you favorite and best my favorite movie
is ghostbusters best movie I've ever
watched um god I don't know maybe the
Godfather Oh do you think Game of
Thrones had too many characters no not
for how long it went I don't think so
can you tell us about the ring well I
mean the it's just a rainbow ring I mean
actually this is this is one sent to me
by a subscriber because my orig
which is sitting over there has a crack
in it that one I picked up at a vintage
store cuz these are actually really hard
to find I don't know where the
subscriber found it but this you you can
find rainbow rings but this specific one
is actually rather difficult to find but
I wear it because I have pride and I and
you know there you go
I didn't hate like oh me too but I
didn't love it waiting to see your video
about it well hopefully I can at least
show you the merit I'm not I'm not
looking to change it it was mind you
like or don't like what you do or don't
but you know I have fun with that
if pickles are wrong I don't want to be
right pickles are the world's most
perfect food dill anything else is a
pretender which movie do you wish you
had seen in the theaters but you
couldn't did it well I mean right now
it's just us haha but there's probably
others pickles are wrong
oh channel pup you and I but those are
fighting words oh they're all God Nick
there is a pickle war going on now dill
Chico and dill pickle potato chips yes
to those banned prawn chips and and dill
pickle chips for all that is what I
shall campaign on that's right I am now
the 22nd candidate for the Democratic
nomination
oh god I hate how long the election
cycle is in this country what you didn't
like about endgame I didn't I didn't
think the the size of Thor's gut was
necessary to make the point I'm a softer
on that now cuz there were some comments
on the review video where some people
who were who described themselves on
heavier said how bad she really
appreciated it so like I'm a little
softer on than it was I still didn't
really care for it personally what about
dill prawn ships Oh Gabe
like that's mad scientists talk at this
point just know
pickles are just fine crunchy so fun but
not that tasty then you are eating the
wrong pickles half sour pickles thank
you like like my my preference would be
garlic dill pickles personally would you
like a jelly baby oh I'd like I gave
them another shot like the I'm still
little put off by the flour on them but
now that I've kind of gotten a handle on
them then I'm bugging me as much
I still don't love them but you know I I
can handle them better now I think I
actually need to wrap it this up I've
gone geez around way longer than usual I
get into these I have a lot of fun with
these um
Haribo jelly babies are better I would I
yeah I would buy that Haribo in general
does just really good stuff um cat or
dog person I mean if you're gonna make
me choose I'm more of a dog person but I
like cats
have you seen community I saw the very
first episode and never got back to it
not cuz I was like I didn't like it I
just never got back to it
it's caster sugar not flour well as
about as bland as flour so whatever it
is all right well don't worry about it
Kara cuz we're actually going to we're
gonna wrap it up weed or drink I don't
really care for weed
so yeah drink you're eating pot well I'm
not eating popcorn I'm eating jelly
babies and now I didn't bring it up for
everybody what you're gonna do give me
detention
ah Thank You
cetera tardis Smith dr. John Smith with
some interesting name some of you folks
have favorites flavor of skittles lemon
fight me all right everybody I hope you
have a great rest of your day I hope you
have a great rest of your week
like I said I've got work to do I've got
a video to shoot I've got other stuff to
edit that's something I'm gonna have
going up on Saturday which is very
different for me and it's something I'm
doing totally on a lark and it's taking
way longer than I thought it would but I
hopefully people will get a kick out of
and yeah for right now that'll that'll
wrap it up did you get detention a lot I
only got detention once I think and that
was for being late torn in Chapel